while you can't kick off a new year
without a whole bunch of promises to
yourself that you're liable to break hey
everybody so I hadn't planned on doing
this I just had the idea and I'm just
kind of throwing this together fairly
last-minute but I heard to me that I
didn't I don't really have like a proper
sort of quick look back at like the
channel um for 2019 and kind of a look
ahead to 2020 and what's gonna happen
it'll be the same what'll change so on
let's start with a quick look back to
2019 2019 I would be I'd be lying if I
said that was um you know everything was
good in 2019 I did a lot of work that
I'm quite proud of and I'm I'm happy
with my work in 2019 but the channel
growth slowed significantly 2018 I
picked up about 20,000 subscribers this
past year I picked up about 10 which is
nothing to sneeze at and I'm super
grateful for but it is a slowdown so
with that in mind well that makes me
paranoid switch to my kid [ __ ] okay we
got to start over
well you know it it wouldn't be a new
year if you didn't make a bunch of
promises to yourself that you're
probably gonna break hey folks thought I
hadn't planned on doing this this is I'm
throwing this together very last-minute
but I had the idea so what the heck
because I didn't actually sort of plan
out any look back at 2019 and or look
forward into 2020 so I'm kind of doing
both in one go with this 2019
was a little bit of a mixed year for me
as far as YouTube goes um my you know my
personal life outside of YouTube pretty
good 2019 for the most part but as far
as YouTube goes I'm happy with my work
and my output for the most part it was a
slower year for me though growth wise
2018 was big for me I gained 20,000
subscribers that year I gained 10 this
year which is nothing to sneeze that and
I am super grateful for I don't want to
come across as as an ingrate but things
did kind of slow down and I had to sort
of readjust my expectations it's an easy
thing to sort of put the blinders on
when things start to go on a trajectory
to think they'll just keep going it'll
keep going up and well no it won't and
intellectually I kind of knew that
emotionally I don't know if I was kind
of prepared for the wake-up call
20:19 gave me as far as that goes but
I'm one of the things I'm gonna try and
do for myself in 2020 is to try and not
be as focused on the subscriber growth
or the growth of the patreon I'm never
gonna stop caring about those things but
I'm trying I'm gonna try and focus much
more on the work that I do and not as
much on you know using those as a
measure of success I think one of the
things that will help me do that is I
this this past year I started the
breakroom of geeks which if you're not
already subscribed why not hop on over
there
there isn't a regular upload schedule
over there but it also gives me a place
to put things that maybe wouldn't
actually be successful here because at
this point I am big enough that I do
have to kind of be careful about you
know putting something out that I don't
think will do well because I'm not gonna
lie I would very much like to get this
between this and the patreon gets the
point where
this could actually be what pays my
bills this could be my job especially
because I think I could really up my
game in terms of what I am able to do in
terms of my output if I wasn't also
holding down a full-time day job but
until that's the case it is very helpful
for me to have a secondary place to
stick things because if you're trying
for that kind of growth you don't want
to be putting up stuff that is gonna
drag the whole channel down so having
breakroom of gigs sort of it freed me up
in a lot of ways just sort of it just
sort of felt like a weight off my
shoulder because I now don't feel like
I'm restricting myself with the main
channel by doing what I kind of was
already doing which was having an eye on
the views going like oh well that didn't
do so well or who this sort of thing
does well maybe I should do that again I
don't like having that be super
dictatorial about my output but I kind
of need to at least to a certain degree
to sort of keep the the channel growing
but weird
one-off ideas that don't really have a
place here I now have a place to put
those so that's cool and I'm hope I'm
hoping that that will help again there
will never be a regular upload schedule
for the break room but it's there and
stuff will turn up there and now drop in
the community tab here when I do so
people can pop on over there and check
it out the biggest change that happened
this past year was I came into the year
having done a video a day for hey I
forgot how long I actually managed to
pull it off for it was probably close to
10 months but I stopped that I brought
it back to four videos a week and that's
the schedule I intend to keep now some
weeks especially industry in December in
November I did end up doing more than
that because you know I now plan my
docket in advance much more and that
means that when something comes up that
I either didn't know was going to happen
like a trailer drop or something that I
forgot to account for like honestly I in
the
month I forgot to put revealing star
wars on the docket but it gives me empty
days to slot that into if I don't want
to shift other stuff around but four
videos a week is going to remain the
plan especially because one of my big
goal is going into 2020 and this is
something this is behind the scenes you
guys I don't know if you'll see the
fruits of this a ton but behind the
scenes I really need and I'm starting to
get there again but I need to rebuild my
cushion because I used to have a cushion
of about a week close to two weeks worth
the videos that were done at any given
time like a week and a half two weeks
worth of stuff is already done now it's
not necessarily the immediate next two
weeks maybe it's like a few videos here
and then a week down the line and like I
need to do these but like I had a
cushion of stuff that was already done
that pretty much got burned off over the
summer when I had a family vacation
followed fairly quickly after by going
to terrific on with Liz and after that
my Christian was gone now I never really
felt behind my schedule I kept I kept up
but I was always like sometimes
literally the night before I shot did
something I'm night before it went up
and I'm really trying to dial back am I
doing that I kind of only want that to
happen if that was my intention like I
saw something reviewed it and it goes up
the next day like that'll happen when
when the new Doctor Who starts coming
out because I want to turn those around
quickly but short of that I really want
to build my cushion back up because once
it's there it'll hopefully lower my
stress a little bit and I know I can
build it back up I don't think that's
behind this guy because I used to have
that and I want to get it back and I
think I can so that's something that I'm
looking into going into the new year I
am I don't know when for sure that it's
going to happen I am going at some point
in 2020 be running a
crowd funding for my novel for my
fantasy novel that I wrote that I've
been you know getting feedback from beta
readers on revising and working towards
publishing I'm going to be running a
crowdfunding for that it's probably
gonna end up being through Kickstarter
which I don't love that because they've
I got some issues with the way the
company is being run lately but I I
don't think that I can afford to take it
somewhere else to be because simply be
blunt about it
Kickstarter is the best platform to for
people to find your thing and things
like IndieGoGo really kind of only work
if you can count on putting out enough
of a call to action outside of the
crowdfunding platform itself to get all
the people in that you need a
Kickstarter you know people a lot more
people are on Kickstarter and a lot more
people are browsing Kickstarter for a
type of thing that maybe they want to
back and I kind of need that so we'll
see that's probably where it's gonna end
up being and I don't know if someone's
gonna happen I want it to happen in the
first half of the year because I would
like to have the book done and published
before the year is over I've been
working on this thing for freaking ever
and I would like to move on another goal
for 2020 I want to get an audio book
version of the book I've already
published skirting gender I want to get
that done so that's another goal and
these are some of the things like that
are the kind of thing that are really
hard for me to get done it's part of the
reason I need my cushion back but it's
also the kind of thing that I would
really hope I could get done you know on
a more reliable and predictable schedule
once if and when this ever becomes how I
actually make my living there's there's
kind of one other thing going into 2020
and this is something I've been thinking
about off and on for the tail end of
this year which is I'm gonna change the
methodology behind how I present in
videos so I mean as I'm pretty sure you
all know at this point I'm gender-fluid
and I've got I've got all this badly
needs to be recolored I'm trying to
schedule that but up to this point I've
really only had it down for the
livestreams and when I've been talking
about lgbtq+ topics basically what had
been happening up to this point was that
the subject matter of the video was
determining how I presented if my gender
fluidity felt like it was relevant to
the topic I would present with the hair
down
maybe with dangly earrings and maybe
even pick up my voice a little bit be
not necessarily as as a mask or
something like that but because it's
something I tend to do when I'm in a
more feminine mindset so there you go
but otherwise I was I had the Hat and I
presented more masculine I'm not gonna
do it that way anymore
and now that's not me saying that I'm
gonna get rid of the Hat and never wear
it again but I'm now going to just start
letting me and where I'm at when I shoot
something determine how I look within a
certain degree because like for the
overdue Doctor Who reviews Isis I will
still cosplay as whatever doctor so like
I'm gonna keep wearing the Fez as I
worked my way through the alot of doctor
stuff so like that won't change but
other than that I'm not going to present
the way that I think looks best because
honestly that was that was part of why I
did what I did part of me was always
kind of afraid that if I looked like
this in the thumbnail
or if as soon as somebody clicked on it
that there will be a chunk of bodies
that I would immediately lose who would
look at me go I want to hear from
somebody like this and they click off
and go away and to a certain degree
that's probably even true but I've
reached a point where it's better for me
and my sense of self to stop worrying
about that and that the funny thing is I
also know that that lift worked in the
opposite direction as well because I've
had more than a few people tell me
you've leave comments saying I didn't I
used to get yourself in recommendations
and didn't click on it for a long time
because with your hair up in the Hat and
the glasses you look you looked like the
kinds of geeky channels I avoid so at
this point you I mean the long story
you're gonna see the hair down more
you're not going to see the hair down
all the time some days I frankly want to
wear the hat and on those days they will
also some days I just think my hair
looks like trash and I don't want to
deal with it and I'll probably wear the
hat then too but I'm gonna stop
presenting in a way that is quote
unquote topic appropriate at least as
far as like my presentation of me like
it'll be topic appropriate in terms of
like outfit like I said cosplay stuff I
love to wear it but as far as the hair
goes and whether or not I'm wearing
dangly or earrings or whether I'm
wearing bees or the cat eye frames or
the rainbow frames or whatever it's
gonna be determined solely by where I'm
feeling and where I'm at at the time I
shoot the video and it's no longer gonna
be dictated by me worrying about
somebody clicking on it and seeing me
and going up because at this point I'd
like to think that my not being
cisgender is a known enough quantity
that if people really aren't going to
pay attention to me
because of that you know they were gonna
find out very quickly anyways so what
would I what would I get
what would I benefit from trying to
tailor myself for anybody else at this
point
I get a handful of views on a few videos
but they wouldn't stick around because
if they were gonna be put off by me
looking like this they'd scroll through
the video feed see me looking like this
and go away anyways so I suppose that'll
be the most visible change is as you'll
see the hair more which hopefully will
also will give me more incentive to get
off my butt and get it recolored because
like the I see it this frigging there's
like barely a hint of pink there's a
little bit of blue when this is all just
now blonde like I got off I gotta fix
this and maybe me having to stare at it
in the monitor on the camera well will
keep me from letting it get this faded
again that would be nice too but I think
I think that's about it still planning
to do four videos a week standard plan
is still gonna be two of those being
Doctor Who I'm going to continue to do
the overdue Doctor Who review as I
finish off Matt Smith I will start doing
reviews of stuff I actually already have
reviews on I will keep going through
Capaldi and it will become the take to
Doctor Who review so that's part of the
plan other than that I will continue to
talk about lgbtq+ representation I will
continue to you know work with my folks
on patreon to get their opinions have
them vote on topics
I'll keep plugging it because I really
love doing this and the size and growth
and what I have right now the platform
that I have right now is incredible and
just the idea that this could be what I
do for a living this and stuff connected
to it
just the idea that that's even vaguely
possible and it's not stupid for me to
think that that might happen that's
amazing
we'll see what the new year brings I
don't know if I'll get there I don't
know if I'll ever get there
but I'm gonna keep working I'm gonna
keep plugging away and hope you'll stick
with me
and I hope you have a good day a year so
all the usual stuff you know the deals
links and buttons and likes and
subscribes and comments a lot hearing
from folks patreon link is in the
description yeah I know all those things
that you can do but you don't have to
because I'm sure you've got your own
resolutions to worry about Plus at the
end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]